[Musique]
cette sirène les ukrainiens la
connaissent trop bien elle annonce
l'imminence d'un bombardement et invite
la population à se mettre à l'abri
ses habitants se réfugie 20 mètres plus
bas dans les catacombes de death à
2500 km de tunnel
alexandre organise cette nouvelle vie
souterraine
[Musique]
en journée ce sont principalement des
femmes et des enfants qui s'y réfugient
au kenya snowboy ims octobre au 8
juillet james r by emergency
depuis le début de l'offensive russe des
bénévoles comme alexandre livre de quoi
tenir et ont même installé internet pour
rester informé
des
goodwill
pour que
les frappes des navires us sur odessa
ces derniers jours ont décuplé
l'angoissent de cette mère de famille
mongole et cochrane comme voilier
quant à l'équateur
en cause
en cas d' attaque de grande ampleur les
autorités d'odessa compte sur ses
kilomètres de catacombes pour sauver la
population
plus